好 虽然指数没有创高
但我们有发现
有蛮多族群都有代表股创高了
例如今天星星 景硕 载版
我们一直都帮大家追踪的
可是大家难免要问
创高不敢追 没有问题
今天为了要教我们一个配对交易
这个太猛了
刚才我先偷看你的图
所以你要发现
现在其实有一些主流
已经先表态了
还没等大盘
我们先告诉大家
我是最强的
载版很强
铜博今天也有表态
军工到底该怎么看
今天雷虎没有所涨停
还杀尾派
我想其实回答的Vair Rubin量产
让很多AI科技股
真的吃了定心丸
那这一波
当然指数慢慢已经来到
4万6逼近前高4万8
其实基本上指数
只要大概在推升
不到5个百分点
就能够创新高
那我们应该是先买
创高的股票
还是去找一些
目前可能还在
底部制服的股票
我个人觉得
其实从7月份的
所谓的小股灾发生以来
那这一波呢
指数已经算是V转了
那确实呢
因为有很多领头羊
包括像铜箔基板
光通讯散热
这里面呢
大家看这个是呢
这个分类股的指数
这基本上几乎都快要创新高
那根本要说像铜箔基板
台光电台药联毛
前后连续都有创新高
那散热里面也有齐鸿建策
光通讯联雅
那还有像这个
大力光虽然还没有被纳入这个指数
不過也有包括像光環等等
其實都大漲
我覺得就是有點像打仗的時候
打仗的時候
如果我們都快要攻一下
那攤頭寶
怎麼樣
那你前面衝過去的
這第一批的將士
你能夠往後退嗎
絕對不能
你一路只能攻過去了
這個氣勢才會強
所以我認為在大盤準備
要去攻48000的過程
這些創高的股仍然是首選
第二個原因
因為現在的成交量
虽然有稍微温和放大了
两到三天
但是还没有看到
单日回到一兆元以上
还没 今天本来以为有
对 如果现在成交量
已经回到1.2兆
1.3兆 1.5兆
那当然就会扩散
到更多可能低位阶的股票
也会开始反攻
所以我这个现阶段
如果你资金有限
操作节奏上
还是先抓这些
比较强势的领头族群
然后持续地去观察
落后股里面
有没有便宜又大碗的标的
这是第二次挑战反弹4万6000
已经发现有人是两波都抢
有人是本波没跟上
你建议看两波都抢的
对 那就代表说是市场的聪明资金
包括大户跟法人先锁定的
那这也表示说
其实这一轮的急煞在跟V转出现之后
真的有点财富重分配
因为如果你看指数好像
已经几乎快要回来了
没事情了
死报原来的标的
有的套牢说穿了到目前为止
一个月了还是套牢
那刚刚提到的
像这个铜箔基板
或者是说像窄板
都是目前盘世当中
特别有高能见度
那法人资金非常认同的族群
那我们常说
像窄板有四雄
但我更喜欢讲的是三加一雄
为什么呢
因为大家可以看一下
南电新兴跟景硕
其实他们的ABF跟BT的比重
相对都是很高的
纯度很高
那当然呢
真顶在全世界的PCB
它的產值是第一大的
近年來也積極擴廠
然後投入到載板的發展
不過事實上如果以現階段它的BT跟ABF加總起來其實大概只有一成左右相對來說這個時候我覺得磐絲因為剛才講資金量還沒有那麼大
市場的氛圍也還沒有到說
真的一片樂觀
所以這個時候
它的評價就會有點尷尬
到底是要適用載版的高本益比
還是回到以前PCB
比較低的本益比
我們會發現這一波
其實南電跟星星
先後都曾經來到了
就是四位數 千元
可是我發現
這兩張股票當然你買誰
我覺得都不會有錯
可是如果要增加一點操作樂趣
樂趣嗎
或者是貪心
想要再多賺一點價差的話
我常講 錢有限
那怎麼做呢
配對交易
什麼意思
因為南電未來的EPS
會顯著高於新興
而且會拉開
我們可以讓大家再看一次
你會發現到
2027 2028
持續漲價
對耶
明年開始就會開始拉開來
然後如果真的那個難見度
延伸到2028年
南電可能是要來到110塊
新興是66塊錢
就拉開來
差那麼多
順帶一提
景碩基本上
明年EPS還輸給新興
可是到2028年之後
可能會比肩
甚至有點微幅要超車
這是來自於
外資高盛證券的預測
對 所以回到這個EPS的角度之後
我們再來看
股價就知道說
因此
當南電如果落後新興的時候
像今年五月份的時候
我認為這就是嚴重不合理
那這個時候
你不用死爆新興
我反而會把新興賣一趟
或減碼
把副分資金挪去操作南電
你看這一段
南電的股價就很強
創下歷史新高
好 結果它一下子衝過頭之後
不斷領先新興
拉開了高達400多塊錢的時候
因為這段時間
新興確實就很弱
還真的相反
通常在我自己觀察
大概如果差距到了400塊的時候
那這個時候呢
反而我又會從南電的資金撤出來
轉戰新興
那你看喔
這一波上來新興是先創高了
不過呢
昨天喔
這兩者幾乎又是平起平坐
一個1200 一個1180
沒差距怎麼辦
結果呢
今天南電好像聽到了我的召喚
今天就噴上漲停
不過喔
景碩喊缺貨這個也不意外
但我形容說
他好像也順便幫很多同業開了法說會
因為有一個重點
他提到其實他現在營收
還沒有真正來到他的天花板
還應該有更強的成長
可是相對受到缺料的影響
缺什麼呢
像TGAS 薄鮮部
所以他開完法說會之後
南亞很強
那包括其實像昨天富橋也蠻強的
當然景碩今天也是創新高
那這個大家其實就是觀察一下
只要投信持股還在加碼的話
我覺得沿著五日均線
往上去做移動停曆是沒有問題的
但是一般來說
如果碰到四位數
就是一千大塊的時候
可能會稍微震盪一下
但是剛剛提到
既然往上游來講缺料
會不會下一個
也準備要來挑戰四位數的
是金居呢
因為上游材料
雖然富橋最近復甦了
可是前陣子其實都沒它的戲
金居也是
股災的時候跌得超級慘
所以會不會回到
封在材料的身上
因為這個千金
我是不敢打包票
如果有問題請找高盛證券
現在才500不到
高盛的目標價940大家看看就好我覺得重點是什麼看看就好嗎其實不管是高盛的预估或其他外资还有本土反而预估我觉得那个成长的方向非常一致
非常一致
今年我们都知道
京居其实获利没有很好
对
所以你如果从今年角度
都会觉得本益比好高
对
可是2027到2028
那我觉得估且
也不要先去管2029
对
所以我刚才正想问你说
2029能信吗
那我觉得现在看2027
是最有把握的
以现在它的股价来说
其实你就发现
本一笔还在一字头
它真正的业绩爆发的主身段
本来就是落在
从大概今年的第三季
开始启动到明年
所以上半年的业绩不好
或是说今年一整年EPS
好像没有很特别高
我觉得都算是正常的
那比较特别的是
股价当然前面过的时间
大家辛苦了
跌得跌很深
但是因为卖方看起来
也有点息受
所以你有没有发现
它这一段下跌的过程当中
其实没有太大的量
我可以感受到息壽
因為很多股民就會覺得
這麼有競爭力的銅箔
是高階的 有寡占地位的
為什麼會跌成這樣
可是今天這樣
你說不心痛是不可能的
既然如果沒有融資
那我就息壽 續爆 忍耐一下
忍耐 忍到什麼時候呢
忍到 就是現在
為什麼呢
通常我量最喜歡看是均量線
大家看這兩條線
紅色跟藍色
五日跟十日均量線
那我先用五日均量線來畫
這個地方你看
它當時的均量在這個位置
现在的均量在这个位置
多很多了
左边下跌这个过程都没什么量
右边落底反攻打底的过程
你看最近的量都蛮大的
所以我觉得代表现在大户开始
又重新吸纳筹码了
逢低去做回补跟加码
那很好玩的是
外资其实都站在卖方
甚至投信也站在卖方
可是他们卖了这么多连续卖
股价从270涨到500块钱
谁 是谁
那就表示有聪明钱
又是充名前
把筹码收走了
那因为业绩好的公司
7月营收创新高
如果8月再开出
漂亮的成绩的话
我觉得法人
大概率就会回补
再加上这一条
重要的中期多空线
也就是季线
今天收盘站上去了
那我知道很多资金
其实它往往会看什么
就是你的中期趋势
有没有扭转
站上季线之后
包括一些城市交易
都可能会做回补
好 这个就看法人
跟不跟 对不对
对
好 那三位朋友
他如果这一波下到了
到什麼時候會是比較好的停歷時機
我覺得大家其實
接下來你就看
只要它開始爆量之後
流上引線或黑K
就像你看它前面
這個地方都會開始流上引線跟黑K
那這種狀況之下就代表
我們講這一段聰明前
開始繞跑了
或者如果真的後續發生
外資買 投信買
顛倒過來想
怎麼股價漲不動了
那也是聰明前在繞跑
二流的看外資投信
但一流的你要看
跟外資投信對坐的
好 很特別的觀察
好 這個是在同伯的部分
那今天有一個最新的新聞
就是無人機的條例
通過的版本是2400億
或是一個mix的版本
不過這個軍工股很奇妙
都會先知道或先壓寶
但尾盤殺下來
是覺得這個條例不夠吸引人嗎
到底該怎麼判斷
這個懸而不決
我覺得是對產業是最大的傷害
那一旦確定了
我覺得朝野一致的方向
雖然細節內容不同
可是大家都知道
台灣要發展無人機很重要而且我們還要吃到國外的政策那之前美國的關稅政策其實擺明就是去紅化所以也有利於台灣的訂單永路因此在投資國防軍工股當中
很簡單 我認為就是
八字決 內外要通吃
海路要雙漆
海就是無人艦 無人艇
那路則是在無人機的部分
那其實我們來看一下
這一次最重要的指標股漢翔
它其實已經接近創高了
那它市值最大
所以漢翔能夠高姿態
那就代表大資金沒有跑
它認同會往上
那再來今天一早
很快就升空起飛的
是雷虎
它的股性向來就是最活潑
所以雷虎會長也代表
靈活的資金也知道
這個有細唱
後面有行情
所以因為國內的軍工國防股
相對來講他們股本都很小
那這個2400億的商機
我覺得應該初期來講
雨露均沾
沒有哪一家公司
有足夠大的產量跟股本
把這個商機說
我幾乎要通包了
所以應該都會雨露均沾
那尤其股本小的公司
你就要留意一下
籌碼的集中度如何
那這邊我會先建議
就是一個去看一下
這個反制無人機系統的創紅科技
因為雖然我們都很熟
剛剛講的漢翔 雷虎 長榮 韓翰
可是你今天選的
可能是投資朋友比較不清楚
在軍工裡面有符合你講到的
內外要通吃
海路要雙漆這件事
那因為它本身就是代理
這個反制無人機系統
那大家應該有去看過
美國有些納斯達克公司
ONDS
那它已經收購了
以色列這家公司
所以等於現在這個產品
就是由創紅來說一個代理
好 認識一下
當然它相對來說
成交量是比較小
所以切記呢
操作這種股票
千萬不要自己追高的模式
你要拉回在它的上升趨勢線附近
去留意是不是浮現了
轉強的機會
好 大家籌碼看起來
有一點點像隔日沖
在琢磨要不要擔心呢
这简单来说
因为相对就刚刚你有提到
比较大家不熟悉
所以过去它焦头比较清淡
所以有时候会有一些资金
专门在做量
是 做量
进出 进出
这个就是做量
它量就是慢慢有一点
你看增温出来了
但是确实你要留意
因为上一波这个地方
它的量真的比现在大蛮多的
所以这个就要看
是不是像汉翔 雷虎
真的能够把整个产业的
那種攻擊的氣勢帶出來
如果有更多資金進來
我覺得這個地方
它就有機會去做突破
好 反制無人機
對 那另外軍工產業
還有一個這個新小旗
新的題材 小的個股
然後旗兵
我好久沒聽到這三個字了
新小旗 對
多麼棒的領悟
發現原來栗三已經從
工具機再跨到健身器材
再跨到無人機的動力系統
大家可以到官網去查查看
這是官網下載的圖片
它其實主攻就是
無人機的馬達跟動力系統
那目前已經其實接到
非常非常多的訂單
所以看起來呢
有這個第一波先知者已經進場
那拉回整理之後呢
目前也是呢
重新讓它的一個均線
糾結整理之後翻揚往上
所以看起來呢
今天早盤也一度有攻擊的企圖
不過剛好這個地方
有一個空方缺口啦
所以今天留了一個上影線
那就看明天
或是下個星期
無人機整個族群
是不是還能夠凝聚市場資金
好 因為剛剛講到的
像栗山它也算是多題材了
所以這個條例通過
我們就觀察領頭羊 雷虎 亥想
能不能拉出一波比較長的漲勢
這邊非常謝謝微良